[موسيقى]
موسكو تعلن موعد الحرب العالميه الثالثه
وتؤكد قريبا سيزول احد الطرفين اما النيتو
اوكرانيا فما الذي يخطط له الروس يا ترى
ومن داخل اراضيها فلندا توجه ضربه
لانتقاميه لروسيا بينما الحرب تشتد على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وستمائه قتيل اوكراني
خلال يوم واحد فهل تلك الارقام حقيقيه
والدوائر العنقوديه تتساقط على الجيش
الروسي فكيف ستكون رده فعل بوتين واشنطن
تشير الى سلاح جديد يدخل ارض المعارك
الاوكرانيه وماكرون يهاجم روسيا مجددا
ويسعى لرضعها تحت اي ظرف وبعد ان سلم نفسه
ها هو قائد فاجنر يسلم سلاحه الثقيل
والخفيف لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه واردوغان
يخلف بوعضه امام المسلمين وعقبات
شقيقتكم ها هي كوريا الشماليه تفي بوضعها
والولايات المتحده وحلفاؤها يقررون الرد
وبقوه والمعارك تندلع بين لبنان واسرائيل
النيت يقلب الطاوله على
ان اجتمعت ومجموعه السبع لليوم الثاني على
التوالي ها هي اليوم الطاولات ذاتها تشتعل
لتخرج ما في احشائها ولا صوت يعلو فوق صوت
الحلفاء في قمه انتظرها العالم لاشهر
وانتظرت اوكرانيا على احر من الجمره وفي
النهايه خاب املكياب ولم يتم ضمها للنيتو
لكن البيت الابيض كشف انه سيتم الاعلان عن
ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا للاشتراك مع
مجموعه السبع وليس ذلك فحسبه بل واعلنت
مستشاره البيت الابيض ان خطه تامين
مساعدات عسكريه طويله الامد لاوكرانيا من
دول مجموعه السبع تظهر لروسيا ان الوقت
ليس لمصلحتها فعن اي وقت يتحدثون
واوكرانيا تنتهي وتتدمر بمرور الوقت لتاتي
الاجابه فورا وعلى لسان وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجيلافروب بتصريحه ان الصراع
[موسيقى]
الموجهه بعيده المدى وبالعوده لقضيه
انضمام كييف للنيتو وبعد ان كان وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني متروكوليبا قد صرح في
وقت سابق بان اوكرانيا لا تعرف ما هي
الشروط التي يجب تلبيتها للانضمام الى يجب
ان يصيغها اجابت عليه صاحبه الردود
السامال المتحدثه الروسيه
بقولها ايها الغبي عليك ان تتعلم قواعد
اللعبه مع الغرب قبل ان تبدا وليس بعد ومن
المعارك السياسيه الى الحروب المتوقعه
اشتعالها فهنا بولندا تضع يدها على شركه
روسيه على اراضيها ضاربه بالقوانين
الدوليه عرض الحائط وذلك عندما صرح وزير
التنميه والتكنولوجيا البولنديمار بودا
بان بلاده بدات بيع اصول شركه نفرغرين
انرجي التابعه لشركه نوباتيك الروسيه يزيد
الرئيس البولندي اندري دوده من صب الزيت
على النار معلنا عن تبني حلف النيتو خطه
لنشر 100 الف جندي من الخلف على اراضي
بولندا في اطار الخطط الدفاعيه مما يتمركز
حاليا على اراضي بولندا حوالي عشره الاف
جندي من حلف الناتو معظمهم من القوات
المسلحه الامريكيه اذا لماذا يذهب دوده
الى نار الحرب ضد روسيا بالمنفاخ ما الذي
يثق به هذا الرجل دوده ليس وحده وهنا وصف
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل روسيا بالضعيفه
عسكريا مؤكدا ان الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
مستدام وهنا نعود قليلا نحو المعارك
الضاريه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه حيث اعلنت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في مقاطعه عن
استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه مدينه توكماك
في المقاطعه باستخدام الذخائر العنقوديه
وذلك في اول استخدام لها بعد ان زودتها
واشنط هذا النوع من القنابل ليرد بانه
سيرد باستخدام الذخائر مماثله والحرب
تشتغل يا ساده من جهتها اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه احباط 30 هجوما جنته
القوات الاوكرانيه والقضاء على اكثر من
600 جندي خلال اليوم الماضي كل يوم 500 او
400 او 700 هم ما بيخلصوش ليه مهلا يا هذا
فنحن لا ناتي بشيء من عندنا نحن نتصفح
المصدر كما تشاهدون نعم هذا هو الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه وظن الجميع يعلم
ويعرف ان هذا الموقع هو تابع لروسيا اليوم
وفي سياق اخر اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان مجموعه سلمتها اكثر من 2000 قطعه من
المعدات العسكريه بينها دبابات وحوالي
2500 قطعه من الذخيره وكذلك نحو 20 الف
قطعه سلاح وها هي قمه النيتو المنتظره من
اجل اوكر ننتهي لكن النتائج جاءت في صالح
السويد وبعد رفض تركي قاطع على مدى الفتره
الماضيه اي انقره لمطالب الغرب وتقبل
بانضمام السويد للنيتو وذلك حين اعلن
الامين العام لحلف الناتو ان الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وافق على احاله
طلب السويد الانضمام للحلف الى البرلمان
التركي فلماذا اخلف وعوده السابقه لنشاهد
ماذا قال سابقابيه
اذا لماذا غيرت رايك ورجعت عن بعضك يا
حفيظ ارطغرل الاجابه تاتي من صحيفه
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه لبلاده بعد فوزه في الانتخابات
لتعلن وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن قد اكدت دعمها لعمليه بيع
طائرات اف 16 لتركيا فهل اتضح السبب الان
الاحداث والتطورات بعد تهديدات شقيقه
[موسيقى]
للرد على امريكا وحلفائها في المنطقه ها
هي تطلق صاروخا باليسليا باتجاه البحر
الشرقي وحذر الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي جارته
ش من انها ستدفع ثمن هذه الافعال وافادت
توكيله اصاهل اليابانيه ان الصاروخ حلق
اربع وسبعين دقيقه وهي المده الاطول
مقارنه بجميع عمليات الاطلاق السابقه
وهناك اعلن تحالف واشنطن
انهم قرروا الرد وبقوه على ما وصفوه
باستفزازات كوريا الشماليه على اساس
الموقف الدفاعي القوي بين السل و واشنطن
والتعاون الامني بينهما وبين طوكيو قوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي تقدمت نحو منطقه السياج
الفاصله عند الحدود اللبنانيه بسبب سماع
ذوي انفجار مع تحليق مكثف لطائرات استطلاع
اسرائيليه باجواء جنوب لبنان ليسقط حزب
الله طائره اسرائيليه مسيره بعد استهدافها
عناصر تابعه للحزب
[موسيقى]